- [Voiceover] A convenience store requires
that Ayumi spend $4 or more if
she wants to pay using a debit card.
Donuts each cost $0.80.
Donuts each cost $0.80 or $0.80 each.
A bottle of orange juice costs $1.20.
If d represents the number of donuts
Ayumi would need to buy to pay
for 1 orange juice and the
donuts using a debit card,
which of the following inequalities
best models the situation described above?
Alright, so she needs to spend $4 or more,
and she's going to buy 1 orange juice.
She's going to buy 1
orange juice and d donuts,
d represents the number of donuts.
So let's write this down.
So this 1 orange juice,
this 1 orange juice
right over there, that's
going to be $1.20.
We'll assume everything
I'm writing is in dollars.
That's that, and then how much
is she going to spend on donuts?
Well, the donuts are $0.80 cents each
and d is the number of donuts,
so she's going to spend $0.80 times d,
or 0.80d, we can write it like that,
or we could just write this as 0.8d.
So this is what she's spending
on that 1 orange juice,
this is what she's
spending on the d donuts,
and in order to use her debit card,
in order to use her debit card,
she needs to spend $4 or more.
So this thing right over here,
needs to be greater than or equal to $4.
Once again, greater than
$4, that's the "or more,"
but it could also be exactly $4,
and that's why we have the
equals sign right over here.
So let's see, which of
these choices describe that?
Let's see if 0.8(d +
1.2) is greater than 4.
So before you even see if this expression
right over here is equivalent to
this expression right over here,
you can see, this is greater than 4,
we want to be greater than or equal to 4.
So just like that, you
could rule this one out,
and actually if you distribute the 0.8d,
you will see that you
get something different.
You'd get 0.8d, and then 0.8 x 1.2,
is not $1.20, is not 1.2 right over here.
So we can rule that one out.
0.8(d + 1....
0.8(d + 1.2)
is greater than or equal to 4.
Well let's see, that has a
greater than or equal to,
but if you distribute 0.8d,
0.8 x d is going to be this,
but 0.8 x 1.2 is not 1.2,
it's going to be .96, 0.96.
So that's not going to work out.
Let's see, 0.8d + 1.2 is greater than 4.
We're close, but remember we want
greater than or equal to 4.
And then lucky for us, this
right over here is very similar.
It's exactly what we wrote up
here, with just the difference
that instead of writing
$1.20 they wrote 1.2.
So if you just swap these two around,
you get 0, let me do that
in those same colors.
You get 0.8d +
instead of writing $1.20
I'll just write 1.2,
is greater than or equal to 4.
Is greater than...
Is greater than or equal to 4.
So this is exactly what we had over there,
so I would definitely feel
good about picking this one.
Now if you're doing this is in
timed conditions, I would...
Instead of even doing this,
you could go straight.
Instead of just even
trying to think it through,
you could go straight to
see, "Well which of these
"really describes what's going on here?"
So let's see, we want to be
greater than or equal to $4.
We're gonna spend $1.20 on orange juice,
and then the amount that we spend
on donuts is that right over there.
So you might have been able to
just cut to the chase and pick that one.
Whichever way works better for you.